security or like
no no no no no no no but like some
people may see it as an insecurity or
codependence and stuff like that but I I
think we I can I hope I can speak for
this to us
um that we choose to live our life
together as individuals we are very very
different people
um and I think we we
you know we we choose to live together
but
can I ask you can I do you think yeah
that the reason why you feel that way is
because you come from a different world
because you did say you came when you as
a team when you see your friend that
you're talking about was she born here
yeah yeah she's she's English here and
this is why men are going to the East
and finding wives
I always hear yeah they actually all the
dating coaches say to go to Portland
I think one of the number one
recommended ones to buy a prize
it's not to it's not to buy a bride it's
just like they have more feminine
traditional women that tend to be in
shape and pretty apparently I've never
been to Poland yeah I mean I I grew up
going to school and you know women would
be walking to school in high heels
makeup ready yeah like I've been to
Germany
um which it's not Poland but yeah but
it's like compared to America I couldn't
even hear the girls are like 10 times
prettier like I was in this try again I
went to a wedding I was like oh my God
like they would blow everyone here out
of the world but does makeup and heels
high heels Define femininity no no I'm
not naturally beautiful there is there
is a standard that they want to keep up
they will always want to represent their
men it's not it's not it's a sense of
vanity the same with the Latin women
dressed in a certain way and they have a
certain standard of beauty and I do
understand actually when you look to
certain extremities of the world you do
see femininity in more in like higher
levels it's good for some people it's
not good for some people do you
understand what I mean because actually
when we look at these countries that
have this sort of thing realistically
economically they are suffering in
different ways which means that we need
to look at the society we have issues
here but there's also a certain way that
we work that helps us actually survive
that's corruption that's why things are
kind of messed up still but I say bring
shame back in fact I say that all the
time really you know it isn't like one
of the reasons why and kill themselves
because they're ashamed that they're in
cells what are you talking about
that's not the reason did you say bring
shame back sorry that's terrible you
know
I think men should be shamed for not
getting laid you should try to get later
so then so then like this is what I find
that is interesting because obviously
shame is such a low vibration it's
terrible I think what's going on with
the in the world now and everybody's
starting concerned is that they don't
understand everybody's suffering
mentally this is not about bringing
shame it's about yourself no everybody
needs to be that's what the tools to be
strong you don't need shame to be strong
yeah wait wait you absolutely do need
shame to be strong you do because it's
like if your mom yells at you you learn
not to do something like okay I'll give
you an example I was overweight and then
you know what made me lose weight the
guys at work were saying like oh I would
never date a girl over 200 pounds and I
just hit two like 205 or something and I
was like
yeah
I wrote a marathon yeah I wrote a
marathon because I was like oh no I
can't I can't be there because it's like
that the shame helped me but it's like
you could either be a weak person and
let shame break you or you can be a
strong person and let it motivate you
okay let me give you an alternative that
is one of them you can shame somebody
but you could also say you know what
you could be so much more beautiful if
you're healthier you know try something
like that yeah
if that works worse then America
wouldn't have a Pizza an obesity issue
because genuinely no
denalva people genuinely mean like the
body positivity that's huge in America
we're huge it's not much better here you
guys are much less obesity no no that's
what I'm saying do you know why we're
not why people hear more obese actually
is because they're not taught how to be
better to themselves for example I'm
Portuguese I know listen my diet listen
the diets the the things that people
miseducated all the time the food here
is discussing I'm not gonna lie I come
from Portugal I know the difference
between the population then the
population here it's all because of
miseducation we are not taught to tell
people to have the tools to Independence
that's an excuse me it's not like Jamie
um
in 2022 there is no excuse you have
access to the internet yeah I could type
in a YouTube video and get the world's
best nutritionist giving me a video on
nutrition and it's pretty pretty much
Common Sense fruits vegetables common
sense is not common but at the same time
if you've been programmed from Deep like
reprogramming your brain to eat a
different way it is hard work so as a
lazy Society we're all lazy that's why
we like to watch Quick gratification is
a thing it's easy to press
listen I come from a country of Pokemon
potatoes
yeah but genetics genetics let's go into
it though
one at one at a time one at a time we're
not we're not doing the over talking
then go ahead go ahead my family
your families
put on like five kilos like my
metabolism but I make conscious
decisions and I mean I reckon if I lived
in Poland I'd probably be stick thin I I
probably would it wouldn't you know be
going to the gym and trying to grow my
legs and so forth I'd be trying to be as
skinny as possible but you know I chose
a partner that's in the gym industry and
he teaches me certain things other
things I'll Google myself because he
can't teach me about you know women's
nutrition it's it's all about
accountability and making your own
choices and when I said earlier just
coming back to my point because I I
never finished it I think there's a
difference between shame and bullying I
think it's different when you point out
to people oh you should be doing this
because you're fat you're ugly I don't
think we need that as a society I just
think that yourself you should be able
to look at yourself and see and be
realistic and you know I mean in this
country people go to freaking Asda in
slippers and pajamas and then get back
into their own bed in those clothes I
mean I I but even that is it's not right
for me right do you want to put your
best football forward no matter where
you go no I definitely think the world
needs like bullying
people being offensive because if you
ask anyone that's actually successful
they'll tell you the reason for their
successes is their most negative parts
of their life within doesn't teach
anybody anything when you lose it
motivates you to win like now in school
they're doing like no first second third
place in school you know school um
Sports days you're not teaching children
to win like the guy who's the fastest
doesn't feel special now because the guy
who's the slowest got the same medal as
him you should know that he's the
slowest so there's a gap that now
everything's kind of all Blurred Lines
there's no definitive kind of clear
winner and everybody wants to be the
winner but they don't actually have the
ability all the skills to be the winner
so it's like you need somebody to come
and ruffle feathers a little bit in the
military that's what they do they break
you down I was in the military for six
years and they break literally they
break you down they like as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible